if you'd asked anthony fauci 60 years
ago when he was a student at holy cross
in massachusetts whether he would grow
up to single-handedly control how
christians celebrate their most beloved
holiday fauci probably would have
assumed you were high smoking that tea
with the beatniks in greenwich village
reefer madness he would have been
confused
at the time faucet was studying to
become a doctor not the pope and there
was a difference then
little could he have known back in 1958
that public health would become
america's reigning religion and he its
high priest
but life is like that you never know
where you're going to end up
fast forward to the beginning of last
december anthony fauci was 79 years old
his 80th birthday it turns out was
christmas eve and fauci was determined
to celebrate it with an exhibition of
authority flexing that had no precedent
in the entire history of the federal
bureaucracy no one had ever done it
before but fauci did
he decided to unilaterally end christmas
and so one day on nbc news he did just
that watch
a warning and a plea from dr anthony
fauci should people now cancel their
travel plans for christmas to the extent
possible don't travel don't congregate
together
there was do not travel for christmas
anthony fauci said do not congregate
together to celebrate it that means no
christmas eve in church that means no
christmas morning under the tree with
your family tearing through stockings it
means no christmas at all
sacred christian observance cancelled
until further notice from dr anthony s
fauci md
what a thrill it must have been for him
to say something like that here's a guy
who fully expected to spend his life
giving prostate exams and there he was
declaring the ancient christian calendar
null and void
pretty amazing
but even more amazing was the reaction
that fauci received when he said it the
people in charge loved it they never
cared much for christmas anyway all that
religious talk and unsupervised family
time it faintly seemed like a threat
anthony fauci by contrast was no threat
at all to the people in charge he worked
for them
his job was to do their bidding to
confirm their biases and to never ever
challenge their sense of their own moral
superiority
their job in return was to love him for
it and they did
drive through affluent neighborhoods in
washington dc to this day and you will
see the signs in people's front yards
honk for dr fauci and dr fauci we trust
and above all thank you tony fauci
and they really do want to thank him not
for funding the gain of function
research in wuhan that created kovid no
it's bigger than that they're thanking
dr fauci for the gift of life which he
alone bestows
what you're seeing here is washington's
new religion it's fouchyism
so it shouldn't surprise you that this
year once again our moral leaders are
asking dr fauci the very same question
christmas is coming can we celebrate it
before we go through the hassle of
booking plane tickets renting cars
buying presents for our loved ones
preparing to celebrate the central
holiday of the country's biggest
religion please let us know dr fauci
is it on or off have we been naughty or
nice tell us
this year the job of asking that
question fell to an anchor at cbs news
and this sunday she asked dr fauci
here's what he said
but we can gather for christmas or it's
just too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time
it really depends on how you behave
whether you're naughty or nice at this
point it's just too soon to tell whether
you can have christmas this year
and in hearing that the news lady just
nods of course it's all perfectly normal
we'll check back with you dr fauci keep
doing science as only you can
and of course that's exactly what tony
fauci plans to do it's what he's done
with his life
last week fatchi had to unravel this
scientific puzzle are the hundreds of
thousands of sneezing unvaccinated
illegal immigrants coming into this
country every month driving a spike in
covid cases could that be happening
figuring that out with it was anthony
fauci's job as a scientist
fauci's scientific conclusion
well here it is
are immigrants a major reason why covet
19 is spreading in the u.s
no absolutely not dan i mean if you just
look at the data and look at the people
who've gotten infected look at the
people who are in the hospital look at
the people who've died this is not
driven by
immigrants what
fashionable people getting covered no
absolutely not dana the sneezing
unvaccinated migrants streaming across
our southern border from around the
world are absolutely fine in fact from a
public health perspective they're great
people like blm rioters but very much
unlike donald trump voters in fact these
people may be the solution to this
pandemic if we're going to beat this
covet thing we're going to need a few
hundred thousand more people from haiti
asap they know a thing or two about
public health
thanks dr fauci
meanwhile other non-religious data tell
a somewhat different story the latest
figures from immigration officials show
that fully 18 percent of illegal
migrants leaving border patrol custody
have tested positive for covid that
doesn't even include the unknown but
very large numbers who never wound up in
border patrol custody
more than 25 percent of migrants who
were quote recently scheduled for some
expedited deportation flights have
tested positive for covid what
percentage these people are vaccinated
none
but let's face reality here fauci said
none of that's a problem the real
problem is you and your silly demands to
see your family for christmas
or to be with your aging parents as they
die in the hospital that's the problem
and how you vote
our public health establishment strongly
agrees with this as tony fauci spoke the
cdc ruled out new guidance to match they
caution that people should hold quote
virtual holiday celebrations or have
socially distant celebrations outdoors
at the end of december
we're doing all this keep in mind for a
virus with a median age of death that is
higher than life expectancy in the
united states and also in the united
kingdom let that sink in
in the state of ohio for example where
the life expectancy is 73 the median age
of death from kovid is 79.
that's just public health
but here's the funny thing
not everyone wanted to hear that we need
to cancel christmas it turns out outside
of network newsrooms christmas remains
stubbornly popular in this country and
if there's one thing tony fauci responds
to it's public opinion now fouch is on
television nearly constantly not simply
because he's brilliant and an amazing
talker
and not at all because he's totally
self-absorbed and loved to hear himself
speak but because it's his job as a
public health official and so he
responded this way
that was misinterpreted as my saying we
can't spend christmas with our families
which was absolutely not the case i will
be spending christmas with my family i
encourage people particularly the
vaccinated people who are protected to
have a good normal christmas
with your family but just the way all of
the other disinformation goes around you
say something talking about a landmark
of a time and it gets misinterpreted
that i'm saying you can't spend family
christmas time which is nonsense
so when i said it's too soon to tell
whether or not you can celebrate
christmas what i really meant was of
course you can celebrate christmas what
are you stupid
so tony fauci didn't misspeak you're an
idiot for misunderstanding what he said
you're being very naughty
now this is a strategy tony fauci has
employed before
just a year ago fauci told us that quote
herd immunity would eventually end the
pandemic once 60 to 70 percent of
americans either vaccinated or developed
natural immunity fauci told us we'd be
done we'd be safe
and then out of nowhere the slogans on
the side of the barn got repainted but
no one acknowledged it fauci started
quoting a higher number in television
interviews he started saying 70 to 75
percent of people with immunity at that
point will be good
and then the number rose again
fouchy changed it to quote 80 85
now in december a reporter at the new
york times their job is to report the
news
notice this
and asked fauci about the changing
numbers according to the paper quote in
a telephone interview fauci acknowledged
that he had slowly but deliberately been
moving the goal post
he is doing so he said partly based on
new science
but partly on his gut feeling that the
country is finally ready to hear what he
really thinks
oh
now he's telling us what do you really
think we weren't ready for it before we
just weren't prepared for the truth but
as we grow in our faith
fauci can lay more profundities on us
so yes he was lying
but it's only because you can't handle
the truth
and the media agree with that completely
they've been repeating that message for
months now
so dr anthony fauci the target of an
escalating right-wing smear campaign
scientists should not be under siege
like this marco rubio rand paul josh
hawley have all taken up dr fauci as a
boogeyman the increasing demonization of
dr fauci by donald trump and his minions
of the republican party um it is growing
it's obsessive and watch what they're
doing to tony fauci right now because he
is the new hillary clinton for them they
are making him the pinata of all of
their disaffection and their upset
in one america dr anthony fauci is
trusted and even immortalized
in the other america though he is
tarnished and distrusted
how did dr fouty of all people become a
right-wing boogeyman
here's what they're doing on fox news to
make tony fought you into a right-wing
boogeyman
here's how he's the subject of a
right-wing smear campaign what they're
doing
is they're quoting him
okay and they're comparing his quotes
from
yesterday to his quotes from three
months ago to his quotes from a year ago
and they're knowing that they don't
all add up
that's a smear campaign
but
as
cnn's media analyst pointed out in half
of america tony fauci is immortalized
and that is true it's not just the yard
signs it's the tony fouchy flags the
tony fauci ornaments the tony fauci
clothing the tony fauci welcome mats you
can find it all online now people are
getting tony fauchy tattoos tattoos
showing the date they got vaccinated per
fauchy's orders
some fouchi disciples are literally
tattooing vaccine cards on their arms
but that's not weird
it's just
faith
on msnbc
this is what tony fauci worship looks
like
i could watch tony fauci spit truth at
the disinformation
elves on capitol hill all day long tony
fauci who under normal presidents is
this trusted and usually beloved advisor
who
has an encyclopedic
memory and knowledge last night going
after tony fauci while it was
predictable was still an abhorrent
um and pretty brazenly political effort
it's the muzzling of dr tony fauci who
is respected revered i dare say in the
medical community on capitol hill and
trusted by the public but this man is a
jewel he's an international treasure not
just a national treasure
he's jesus with better shoes
the muscling he was only on msnbc six
times this week you can't stop this man
he's god
and you know who agrees with that
tony fouchy does
as tony fauci reminded us in june tony
fauci is not simply an international
treasure
he's the physical embodiment of science
so if you are trying to do you know get
at me
as a public health official and a
scientist you're really attacking not
only dr anthony fauci you're attacking
science
well there was the third person
self-reference
fidel castro in english
but that wasn't a slip of the tongue
facie meant every word of it tony fauci
is himself a devout member of the church
of tony fauci now take a look at this
still photo from tony fauci's home
office look in the back on the bookshelf
do you see what is that right there
those are tony fauci prayer candles
prominently displayed inside tony
fauci's home
oh
well at least he's real
fauci isn't just the high priest of
fouchyism he's also a true believer
himself i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis